[Musique]
on
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes de métropole d'outre-mer et
de l'étranger à nouveau cette dernière
soirée de l'année est marqué par
l'épidémie et les contraintes renforcée
qui pèsent sur notre quotidien alors en
ce moment j'ai avant tout une pensée
pour nos 123 mille compatriotes à qui le
virus a enlevé la vie une pensée pour
tous ceux qui traversent ce moment dans
le deuil la peine ou la solitude
je n'oublie pas non plus ceux d'entre
vous qui sont touchés par le cos vie de
longs comme ceux qui subissent les
conséquences psychologiques de la crise
sanitaire
je veux ce soir une fois encore en votre
nom à tous témoigner notre
reconnaissance pour nos personnels
soignants pour nos armées nos forces de
l'ordre nos sapeurs pompiers nos
auxiliaires de vie nous aide à domicile
et tant d'autres professions tous
engagés ce 31 décembre
comme chaque jour pour nous protéger
pour prendre soin de nous
les semaines à venir seront difficiles
nous le savons tous le virus circule et
circulera de plus en plus des mesures
ont été prises par le gouvernement pour
y faire face et je vous demande à tous
et tout d'y veiller des secteurs comme
la culture le sport la restauration
l'hôtellerie le tourisme ou
l'événementiel vont à nouveau subir les
conséquences économiques de cette
situation nous les aiderons comme il se
doit et comme nous le faisons depuis le
début de cette pandémie il y aura aussi
nombre de nos activités désorganisés en
raison de ce nouveau variant si
contagieux nous veillerons dans ce
contexte assurer la continuité des
services publics et de la vie de la
nation mais par rapport au même moment
l'année dernière où les contraintes
étaient beaucoup plus forte nous avons
pour nous l'arme du vaccin et les acquis
de notre expérience collective et donc
de vraies raisons d'espérer
nous sommes ce soir au moment où je vous
parle plus de 53 millions à être
totalement vacciner ce qui place notre
pays dans le peloton de tête mondial
nous sommes 24 millions à avoir reçu une
dose de rappel
et notre objectif est de permettre à
chacun d'être vacciné et de faire son
rappel nous pourrons ainsi surmonter
cette vague en limitant au maximum les
restrictions en continuant comme nous
l'avons fait depuis le début
de tout faire pour préserver l'activité
est ce que nous avons de plus précieux
c'est à dire l'école l'éducation de nos
enfants
alors ce soir je veux le redire avec
beaucoup de force et beaucoup de
conviction la vaccination est notre plus
sûrs atouts elle réduit fortement la
transmission elle divise par dix le
nombre des formes graves c'est pour cela
qu'une nouvelle fois j'en appelle aux 5
millions de non vaccinés fait ce geste
simple pour vous pour vos compatriotes
pour notre pays toute la france compte
sur vous
la vaccination est elle seule suffisante
non c'est pour cela que le respect des
gestes barrières contre le virus demeure
essentiel en particulier le port du
masque
tous ensemble nous allons donc traverser
cette nouvelle épreuve en suivant les
mêmes principes que depuis le premier
jour d'abord nous protéger
protéger les plus vulnérables protéger
nos hôpitaux et nos soignants qui sont
sous forte pression alors même qu'il
faut soigner les autres maladies
protéger aussi notre économie et nos
emplois comme nous l'avons fait avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte ensuite nous
attacher sur la base des faits de la
science à prendre des mesures
proportionnées
c'est exactement ce que le premier
ministre et les ministres ont fait ces
derniers jours tout faire pour éviter de
prendre des restrictions qui pèsent sur
nos libertés et veiller à respecter tous
nos principes démocratiques
enfin nous appuyer sur la responsabilité
de chacun principalement se faisant
vacciner pour soi et pour les autres
être un citoyen libre et toujours être
un citoyen responsable pour soi et pour
autrui les devoirs valcke avant les
droits
un autre motif d'espoir et que malgré
les preuves sanitaire malgré la fatigue
la lassitude
notre pays continue à avancer nous
n'avons cessé d'oeuvrer pour attirer des
entreprises aidées investissement ouvrir
des usines créer des emplois jamais
depuis 15 ans le chômage n'avait été
aussi bas la réindustrialisation de
notre pays est bien une réalité
nous avons protéger les travailleurs et
des les plus modestes d'entre nous nous
avons investi pour défendre la dignité
de nos compatriotes en situation de
handicap pris des mesures et des
décisions claires pour mieux protéger
nos enfants accompagnez nos aînés nous
avons formé notre jeunesse en effet qui
aurait pensé que nous serions capables
en cinq ans de doubler le nombre de nos
apprentis près de 700000 apprentis ces
douze derniers mois que nous serions
inventer un programme un jeune une
solution qui a accompagné en un an et
demi plus de 3 millions de français vers
l'emploi ou la formation
là où nous aurions pu tout reporter nous
n'avons jamais renoncé à notre ambition
collective le travail avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le contrat
d'engagement jeunes qui sera mise en
oeuvre au début du mois de mars prochain
le pouvoir d'achat avec l'indemnité
inflation le chèque énergie
l'augmentation des salaires des
fonctionnaires les plus modestes
l'urgence écologique et climatique avec
le renouvellement de notre parc
automobile le développement des énergies
renouvelables rénovation thermique des
logements et au 1er janvier la fin des
emballages plastiques comme de nouvelles
mesures inédites pour le bien-être de
nos animaux notre agriculture avec
l'assurance récolte la retraite minimale
à 1000 euros le déploiement de 2000
maisons de france service le versement
automatique des pensions alimentaires
qui bénéficiera notamment aux mères
seules la gratuité de la contraception
pour les femmes jusqu'à 25 ans et la
réforme de l'état de notre haute
fonction publique avec entre autres la
création de l'institut national du
service public rien que ces dernières
semaines et dans les prochains mois des
décisions dont on parlait parfois depuis
des décennies que je viens à la
cavalcade ici d'essayer de rassembler
ont été prises et seront prises qui
changeront la vie
la france malgré les épreuves et donc
plus forte aujourd'hui qu'il y a deux
ans tout cela c'est grâce à vous grâce à
nous tous grâce à notre esprit de
résistance notre solidarité notre
civisme notre engagement et notre esprit
d'entreprendre
alors au moment où je m'exprime devant
vous ce soir je veux vous dire que je
suis résolument optimiste pour l'année
qui vient optimiste pour notre nation
pas simplement pour 2022 mais pour les
années qui viennent car l'ambition et la
solidarité nous n'avons cessé de faire
preuve nous autorise tous les espoirs
2022 peut-être sera l'année de sortie de
l'épidémie je veux le croire avec vous
l'année où nous pouvons voir l'issue de
ce jour sans fin dans notre pays en
déployant ses campagnes de rappel ans
nous organisons comme il se doit pour
domestiquer le virus est écrasé sa
diffusion et au niveau mondial en
agissant pour vacciner l'humanité la
france dès avril 2020 a été à
l'initiative des dons de doses aux pays
les plus pauvres et nous serons au
rendez vous dans les prochains mois pour
amplifier l'effort et ainsi permettre
d'entrevoir la fin de ce virus sous sa
forme aiguë
2022 doit être l'année d'un tournant
européen
notre continent a été tant décrié ces
dernières années on l'a dit dit viser
incapable de projets collectifs en train
de sortir de l'histoire et alors même
que nous célébrons les 20 ans de la mise
en circulation de l'euro notre monnaie
commune qui nous aura donné une
stabilité monétaire une place
internationale inédite la crise a
démontré qu ni notre europe pouvait être
non seulement utile mais porteuse
d'espérance pour tous sans l'europe nous
n'aurions pas aujourd'hui de vaccins
disponibles en nombre y compris pour
organiser des campagnes de rappel sans
l'europe nous n'aurions pas pu bâtir
partout à travers notre continent des
plans de relance parmi les plus
ambitieux au monde et connaître les
résultats économiques croissance
création d'emplois que nous connaissons
alors à partir de minuit la france
prendra la présidence de l'union
européenne
et vous pouvez compter sur mon
engagement total pour faire de ce moment
qui ne survient qu'une fois tous les 13
ans
un temps de progrès pour vous un temps
de progrès pour la maîtrise de nos
frontières notre défense la transition
climatique
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la construction d'une alliance nouvelle
avec le continent africain le meilleur
encadrement des grandes plateformes de
l'internet et la culture en europe
oui les valeurs que porte notre union
européenne la démocratie l' équilibre
entre liberté solidarité une certaine
idée de l'homme sont j'en suis convaincu
celle qui permettront de relever nos
défis contemporains et notre europe est
bien le seul chemin par lequel la france
sera plus forte face au fracas du monde
et des grandes puissances
2022 sera pour la france une année
décisive une année d'action encore et
toujours fort de votre confiance
j'agirai jusqu'au dernier jour du mandat
pour lequel vous m'avez élu
bien sûr pour tenir le cap et prendre
toutes les décisions nécessaires face à
l'épidémie mais nous aurons aussi à
préparer l'avenir en déployant le plan
d'investissement france 2030 qui vise à
la fois à faire de nous une nation forte
sur les technologies du futur et à nous
rendre plus indépendant nous aurons à
investir plus fortement encore que nous
ne l'avons fait dans l'éducation la
recherche publique la santé la culture
et l'inclusion de tous les français
nous aurons à prendre de nouvelles
décisions pour lutter contre l'islamisme
radical renforcer l'ordre la sécurité et
la tranquillité de tous pour mieux vous
protéger nous aurons à prendre de
nouveaux choix industriels en
particulier en matière d'énergie inédits
afin de tenir nos engagements
climatiques
sera une année d'élection enfin nous
auront à élire au printemps prochain le
président de la république puis à
désigner nos représentants à l'assemblée
nationale
malgré la pandémie ces scrutins
essentiels devront se dérouler dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et
toutes les sensibilités politiques du
pays doivent oeuvrer j'y veillerai tout
particulièrement
nous aurons donc cette année des choix
majeurs à faire pour notre nation ces
choix nous les ferons avec la conviction
que la france un chemin singulier unique
à poursuivre nous les ferons je le sais
en étant fidèle à l'esprit de résistance
l'esprit de tolérance et le choix de
notre avenir commun
qui nous ont toujours inspiré
pour ma part
quelle que soit ma place et les
circonstances
je continuerai à vous servir
et de la france notre patrie
nul ne saura déracinés mon coeur
mes chers compatriotes
j'ai travaillé et nous avons travaillé
sans relâche depuis bientôt cinq ans
afin que la france soit écoutée
respectée en europe et dans le concert
des nations elle l'est à faire
progresser notre pays dans l'unité aussi
chemin bien difficile car il est si aisé
d'opposer les générations les catégories
sociales les origines les territoires
mais chemin nécessaire
car lorsqu'il est rassemblé
rien ne peut résister au peuple français
en vous souhaitant ce soir une année
pleine de bonheur et d'accomplissement
personnel je forme donc pour nous tous
se veut
continuer à respecter nos différences
à avoir confiance en ce que nous sommes
a regardé avec courage audace et
lucidité notre avenir pour agir
décidons pour nous même d'être tout à la
fois enracinés dans notre langue notre
culture notre laïcité
épris de liberté d'universel de
créativité
restons unis
bienveillant
solidaire
restons du côté de la vie
c'est là
ce que nous nous devons à nous mêmes
alors 2022 sera l'année de tous les
possibles
vive notre europe
vive la république
et vive la france
[Musique]
à